the wah welcome to the why the greatest
show on the entire planet Louie
I'm not wearing hair gel that's crazy
I'm me thinking about shaving my head
should I do it smash like on this video
if you agree or disagree right freaking
now let's get into the memes you didn't
have legs when I met him in Tokyo how
dare you how dare you expose me
reporting this Oh God
oh no the subreddit has taken on his
life I'm no longer moderator you know at
some point I'm gonna get kicked out of
my own subreddit just wait for it to
happen I guarantee it yes is anyone even
gonna care that I'm back number one
trending that's right
take that my self-doubt you suck you
stink you were wrong about one thing at
least got you there no you were right
about everything else but you were wrong
about this one Felix coming back from
break Syme nine-year-olds what is this
what's the theme now huh hmm huh what's
your little theme now you know what I'll
decide a theme next theme is whiskey
yeah whiskey theme now you know why cuz
you're nine and you're not allowed to
drink it Oh even 19 year olds can't now
it's time for me to have fun no more
cooking or lame why am I so sassy next
name Tesla to clear forests for Germany
Factory musk says I will plant three new
trees for every one cut oh that's cool
though I like that he did that if only
more people gonna be like a land mush
the world better place to live in
something to think about I got many more
deep quotes if you just let me know
tomorrow I'm back from break the return
of King hallelujah baby I'm back I'm
curious what the comments are now that I
decided to not upload yesterday see in
two days I decided to take weak and soft
everyone but it's Wednesday well
get it yeah if I'm taking a week and I'm
gonna do it when everyone else has it so
it's just like crowded whenever I want
to do stuff duh
god I have to explain these obvious
things I decided to take a break
Wednesday Inter's thing weekend I my
joke to you god damn it so annoying but
your last video was got interest I think
it's a good choice to make I hope it can
give me more time to work on other
things and just relax as well no he did
not do that
Ellen's son has done it again he put
elite a battle agent angel on a rocket
no he did not do that he was supposed to
put subscribe to poot I was a dead man
anyway he did not do that he should have
put pickle wreck on it then he would
truly have my respect he did do that the
absolute mad lag that's so dope
I didn't see elite abandon angel but I
know she came from like the sky thing so
it's kind of poetic homeless that she
would up or just move movement if you
understand do a pickle right next time
ela do it right I want to see you pick a
rake oh man I would make me truly happy
if I see our pickle rake on an Elon Musk
rocket I will be like well you know in
general I question if existence is worth
it pain usually out measures pleasure
but there was a pickle rick on a rocket
once so i think humanity was worth it
that's just my opinion geezers after 2
days in his tomb tomorrow
I'm back from break I like the meme but
don't compare me to Jesus Jesus was way
hotter come on guys shake your phone
gently oh my god
it's the simple things in life it's a
simple base good meme I'll put that one
big baby well done I'm sorry little one
68% aren't subscribed me about to
unsubscribe to get to 69% so can we get
it
69% people subscribe we're at 68 right
now come on guys let's freakin do this
wait what no I have one but at what
price
PewDiePie 4k videos liar oh good one
good one in the future and a couple
decades we'll catch them catch up the 4k
come on you got to give us props that we
moved up to 2880 P at least about 10
years after everyone else did I think
that's at least worth something I think
that's the worth at least a subscribe so
we can hit 69 percent come on I wonder
what the end number actually is I just
said a number I didn't even think about
let me check I was wrong it's 85% come
on guys and so if you got in subscribe
fasting let me see another video
eighty-three percent I've been lying
sorry about that my $300 gaming keyboard
be like it's so tacky isn't it it's so
lame I feel embarrassed whenever someone
has a gaming keyboard I'm like yeah cool
cool gaming keyboard Wow you must do a
lot of gaming on that I can tell it's a
gaming keyboard cuz all the color you
better stop this that I'm back from now
on there's going to be changes this
stupid ice tub ready are you really in
charge you got damn right I am huh
what's the theme then whiskey it's
whiskey I control them I control this
subreddit you cannot stop me the laws of
physics exists goats no what does it go
say no my PT PI 1 layer stencil what no
that's too much effort don't do that
stop it that's too much effort come on
please stop oh god are you gonna no
you're not oh my god
oh my god see I don't even have the
effort to watch the whole thing that's
how little effort I'd oh my god that's
cool what Oh amazing Saracen dub Sun
Devil zoom Duvall art I think I said
that right thank you thank you very much
arigato gozaimasu to the Netherlands the
Netherlands the Netherlands hey shout
out to Netherlands do you know who you
are
that's right Netherlands I know you're
watching looks like pude still hasn't
learned Japanese well that's why we're I
fooled you I would speak in Chinese you
dumb asses I'm wearing a face mask the
joke was what at that so stupid you try
and roast me and you don't even know
what you're talking about
to be fair I probably wouldn't know how
to say it in Japanese but still we've
been tricked backstab and quite possibly
bamboozled he was speaking Chinese I
don't know what he was speaking but it
was definitely not Japanese thank you
thank you that's so cute
I'm moving tomorrow and the old black
lady that lives next to me just said I'm
going to miss you I used to stay up
every night when you would go out with
your friends and I wouldn't go to sleep
until I heard your door closed and I
knew you made it home safe I like this
one that's just kind of obsessive but
thank you I guess pewds is the real life
spider-man the community loves him but
the media hates ya if you wanna get your
beauty pie you got a big for me first
you know with the dr. octopus guy and
he's you've seen the movies I message
you randomly cuz I was bored of watching
fortnight's streams ha ha here by the
way how old are you 7
I'm 22 female what are you up to I'm 7
years old dude I'm eating applesauce
I'm eating applesauce what else do you
want from me I should use that
telemarketers call me while I'm
recording I'm eating applesauce excuse
me
in the car accident a pasar oh my god
that's amazing look how tiny edgar is
and shred ah
minecraft Oh download quicker please oh
wait what what is this how people think
feelings gonna come back how we actually
gonna come back that's just mean Bret
and also very accurate especially with
the beard I don't want to play with you
anymore
yeah it's whiskey now it's whiskey now
Scott damn right it is when it be 4:20
p.m. but you ain't American 69 oh that
is actually really depressing honestly
Phil that one guy's Pierce is uploading
tomorrow quick cleanup the subreddit too
late these are too old stay on the right
path even if you have to walk alone
that's the left path god I'm good
thank you your line what an idiot see
there wasn't one saying every was a
dummy dumb scumbag except me and Elon
we're big brain just me and Ellen Elin
can I go on rocket please please please
I asked I asked I said please pick your
Rick rocket please can I be first pilot
we all hate Ice Age baby but I believe I
found our next target me don't point at
me I'm there's nothing wrong with me why
since Puetz doesn't understand Phineas
and Ferb let's confusing with something
stop it when Pierce comes back rise of
the PP quality mean well done an
intellectual meme a stamp of
intellectual people who have cake day on
29th of February so they have it only
once in four years do you think this is
funny that's true oh my god oh my god
they only have birthday oh my god
teacher these laptops are worth more
than anything you own me with a $5,000
PC how can you afford a $5,000 PC I
couldn't afford a $2,000 in Swedish
crowns
$2,000 shut up bro close your eyes k bro
what do you see my eyes are still here
there brah filthy Frank did at first he
knew he knew our eyes was open when they
were closed before anyone else did
he walked so we could run the best part
about learning Japanese is that you now
understand a filthy Frank lor you're as
beautiful as the day I left thank you
guys I really truly appreciate the warm
welcome back it feels good it feels good
I am reinvigorated with life life force
through memes fingertips PewDiePie I'm
afraid of live-streaming therapist it's
okay we will cross this bridge together
stop it that could be a news anchor can
i Papa Smurf
welcome back babes I've been the penis
pump miss Moorea is still on vacation
this is crazy I've been thinking I mean
thinking I've been playing around with
ideas because I want to do like a weekly
show and then I think a weekly startup
you news recap could be kind of fun like
almost I don't want it I don't want to
say the p-word I don't want to say PUD
but I think something like that could be
interesting Pio news that's what it's
called what the hell is this
[Music]
No
oh my gardening we cooking we painting
weak leg awake pizzas back whiskey we
gamers I like how there's nothing left I
had to celebrate me coming back with the
whole bottle it's normal
see you gamers in two days because I
decided to take weekends off
okay guys I'm never taking break again
liar who's so sorry I know it's hard to
understand that I need a break I need a
weekend I'm just thinking my longevity
okay I don't think it's that weird in
fact I don't even care what you think
unlike other youtubers who scared what
their audience is gonna say I say don't
care what are you gonna do cry [ __ ] your
pants [ __ ] then come maybe what is wrong
with me
I should have never come back this was a
mistake hello would like would you like
yep yep no thank you
okay sorry for offering thanks for
asking first no problem
damn that's so cool if only society more
people like this was I think I'm having
a stroke is I can't form a sentence it's
all coming together
yes power
sorry 69 percent power yes that's what I
said
good joke Felix manga anime Netflix
adaptation I wash that's a Netflix
adaptation al I'll freak the freak Adam
I'll freak myself it's what I'm saying
yes I will have sex with my Harry Potter
and the Goblet in Goblet of vodka nice
very nice
any me girls that wearing her a mask to
protect their health are the kiotas
cringe you're wearing the mask to
protect others okay
it's if you cough you don't want to
spread germs around idiot the mask
itself actually doesn't have much
protection at all from diseases it's
called compassion you might want to look
it up cringe done even when kids comes
back tomorrow we should still have a
theme we're skate day with gay theme
it's a thing yeah yeah yeah
alright gamers that's it for this the
WHA hope you guys enjoyed I had a lot of
fun
I love these thanks for understanding
the weekend thing I know bit awkward but
I don't care
can we hit 68% subscribe let's get a
gamers smash like see you tomorrow and
remember to get a good night's sleep